good afternoon thanks so much for
joining us at four i'm kirsten joyce
christian is on assignment we'll check
in with him shortly but first a reminder
from metro about pool safety
as we gear up for the warmer months
heading our way the warning comes
following recent
child drownings we begin with sasha
loftis who is live in the northwest part
of the valley
where police wrapped up a press
conference a short time ago sasha
[Music]
kirsten the main message here today that
one death
is too many metro police say they've
already seen
two child drownings in 2021 and they
don't want to see this happen again
now a few of the main things they
touched on the first was the importance
of parent supervision
officers spoke about how a child can
drown in just a few minutes
in pools bathtubs sinks or any body of
water
they also spoke on drowning prevention
with things like swimming classes
pool safety fences flotation and alert
devices as well
officers said these accidents can really
happen anywhere
and they just want everyone to be aware
this coming summer
there is not a neighborhood i have not
been in it affects
all races all walks of life
it doesn't matter i have been in every
neighborhood throughout this valley
on unfortunate tragedies relating to
child death specifically drowning
officers tell us both children who died
in this year's drownings were around
three years old
we're told both of those situations were
accidental now lieutenant valente said
that
most situations like this are accidents
but he wanted to
really emphasize that all of them are
preventable
reporting live in the northwest valley
sasha loftis 8 news now